look back to start talk radio I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson and this is our show
about sex since this topic is a little
above my head I bring in my all-purpose
smart guy
Professor Charles Lou Charles welcome
back tonight you know always a pleasure
thanks so much
let me remind people your professor of
astrophysics not professor of sex but
your well thought out on all manner of
topics
you know NASA has an official policy
about sex in space that astronauts are
expected to maintain a constant
commitment to honorable behavior ha I
have some honorable behavior
I would love to demonstrate for them in
zero-g but there's a story circulating
that some space shuttle astronauts
tested 10 different sex positions whoo
whoo whoo NASA disavows all knowledge
knowledge of course they have to yeah
but surely that's what any fertile
people would want to test in space a
superb experiment